Jesus has always been a Fascination for
me I've always wondered about certain
things
certain ideas when they say
Jesus uh freed the world from sin what
does that mean we freed the world from
sin I'm still sinning we make one of two
decisions we either decide to go through
the gate of resentment which leads to
self harm which leads to harm to others
or we go through the gate of forgiveness
which leads to Grace just as Christ did
on the cross he suffered terribly and
the decision was to look upon the people
who were causing that suffering with
compassion and with forgiveness he freed
the world from sin from his perspective
it's up to each one of us to free the
world from sin from our point of view
and that's what opens the Gates of
Heaven